in the beginning there was no life or
death no light or dark there was however
the above and the below above where the
everlasting dragons ruled and below
where there were humanoid beings that
would one day become humans giants and
Lords below fire was born and some
beings found power within these flames
and took it for themselves
Gwyn could be called a lord of light
neato
a lot of death and the witch of izalith
a lord of life these souls were the
despairity they represented black and
white where everything else was gray
before and so they cast away the gray
and started an age of light and dark
life and death there is one that I
haven't mentioned who came after the
other three Lords the furtive pygmy
found the Dark Soul within the flames
and fathered humanity the pygmy was
content to wait splitting and spreading
his soul while the other Lords changed
the world there are dynamics that exist
between the souls you can't have one
without the other wins age of fire is
built around the first flame which was
linked to bonfires and spread throughout
the world however eventually even this
fire began to fade it was realized that
humanity the little black sprite in
every human could feed the fire so Gwyn
commanded his children to Shepherd the
humans maybe there's a reason the Dark
Soul was found after the first three
maybe it was the fuel you already know
what happens next
the gray dragons were cast aside and
Gwyn began an age of fire when the flame
started to fade the witch of izalith
attempted to create a new flame with her
life soul but it spiraled out of control
and demons were created then out of
nowhere a curse appeared a kind of
disease that links humans to the
bonfires causing some to become undying
instead of death there is hollowing and
to reverse the hollowing one has to
offer humanity to the flames convenient
isn't it some even whisper that the
curse was designed by the Lords to keep
the humanity of the undead linked to the
bonfires the more humanity they donate
the greater the fire grows and the
undead are drawn to the flame fated to
be consumed over and over again until
only a hollow husk is left for the
purpose of shepherding the humans the
church the way of white was formed an
influential covenant devoted to serving
the gods they condemned the undead as a
plague the cleric Knights of Lloyd are
praised for their undead hunts using
Lloyd's talismans to prevent the undead
from recovering allowing the Knights to
kill with impunity afraid of the threat
that the Dark Souls pose Gwyn
effectively sets humanity against itself
Undead a quart and shipped the asylum to
await the end of the world so what
happens when a member of the Church
becomes an accursed undead when this
happens it isn't seen as a curse it
couldn't be how could such a thing
happen to a member of the church No
becoming an undead way of white member
means you are blessed it means you must
devote yourself to a pilgrimage in
service of the way of white something
that gets you out of the church but
still serves the church's purpose undead
clerics are given a quest for kindling
the art of feeding bonfires with
humanity is their humanity hidden within
the catacombs maybe but it's much more
likely that they are searching for a
secret right of kindling
a method of feeding bonfires with
humanity that was stolen from an ally of
Gwyn and this brings us to Neto
who was rumored to hold the rite of
kindling until it was stolen by penguin
Neto was a strange entity unlike the
other Lords he seems to only have one
motive above all else we see his desire
to spread death he doesn't concern
himself with the politics of the outside
world except for once when he brought
death to the undying the everlasting
dragons had their stone scales ripped
apart by Gwyn and nito delivered the
death blow but why did he do this well
disparity is in NATO's best interests
because if life exists so too must death
after the successful alliance with Gwyn
Neto gain dominion over the dead and the
catacombs with a vast army of dead
servants defending his tomb and another
army of gravelord servants actively
spreading death to others through the
eyes of death Neto seems content to wait
in the darkest depths of the catacombs
slowly growing his army of the dead like
all the other Lord Souls his power is
distributed among
servants but is there nothing more to
NATO the first undead cleric was Leroy
he was given a glorified set of armor
and the most powerful relics the church
possessed in a grand gesture he was sent
into the catacombs to retrieve kindling
you fight with him to kill pinwheel and
the mission is successful you retrieved
the right from the catacombs which was
stolen from NATO but there's more
attempt to kill NATO and Leroy will
defend him Leroy will fight against you
assume then that NATO is important to
the way of white perhaps his purpose of
spreading death is what Gwyn wants it
makes sense
spread death and the undead have to burn
humanity to feed the bonfires and keep
themselves human feed the bonfires and
Gwynn's age of fire can last a little
longer
the real tragedy here is the deceit we
are all in the dark humanity has no idea
what caused the undead curse but it's
spreading entire lands are becoming
infected with the mysterious dark side
which keeps undead reliant on the
bonfires unable to die no one knows
where it originated no one knows who
created it or if there is even a who
behind it all we do know is that you
could be a regular human before you
turned Undead you'd be unable to die but
unable to stop deteriorating becoming
more and more Hollow with every death
suddenly you're a threat to those around
you
the way of white bizzy's themselves with
purging the undead from the world but
they don't know if the curse is a threat
they don't know how it came about or if
they're just being sent into the
catacombs to die and you you're being
led by serpents who tell you different
things encouraged to kill all of the
lords in your path regardless of whether
they're in your way just so you can get
enough souls to satiate the Lord vessel
in the hope that killing Gwyn will give
you answers there are no answers yet at
the core of everything is the curse
[Music]
we see the struggle of others unfold
around us as they fight for the things
important to them there's a man who
fights on behalf of his broken homeland
another who fights to prevent his
kingdom being broken one man believes in
research for the sake of knowledge and
maybe this knowledge will give you the
power to fix your mistake with this
power